So everybody loves "The Office" so much.
It means so many things to so many people.
I've heard stories of people were sick
and they felt better 'cause they watched "The Office."
Or it's the only thing their family bonds over, you know,
the one time of week they come together.
And now people are like, "You know, this is my fourth time
seeing it through," or "the ninth cycle," and all of that.
So it's been amazing.
It's an amazing ride.
And being a part of "The Office,"
it's like having friends everywhere you go.
You know somebody's gonna know it
and you got somebody talk to or have a beer with.
Where do you think that some of the characters
would be in "The Office" today?
If you projected in your fantasies,
where would you be?
Where would your friends be?
Well, Darryl would probably be somewhere on a private jet.
(audience clapping)
I'm in, I wanna be on a private jet, yes, please.
Anyone else?
I think Meredith is working with AA people.
And I don't think anybody can find Creed.
(Drew laughing hysterically)
He's alive and well, but you just can't find him. (laughs)
Well, I think that gives everybody
something to chew on and they wanna be chewing on it.
"The Office" does transcend.
My daughter and I watch it together, she's gonna be 10,
and it's one of our favorite shows.
We also just watched "The Bad Guys" together.
Really?
And, Craig, you're in it.
You're the shark.
It's such a good movie.
It's so well done.
It's really clever.
It feels a cut above.
There's a lot of intelligence.
I think it's very smart, but it's super fun.
What was it like to do it?
'Cause it really treads a line.
It's a unique tone and it's really good.
It's like Tarantino for kids.
Yes, yes, thank you!
That's it!
Like they knew what they were doing
by casting all of you guys,
and then they made that movie.
It's so good, it's so well done.
Thank you, it was so much fun to do.
We did it over the pandemic.
So it was over Zoom.
And then, I'd be in the booth and having a blast.
The director and the producer, Pierre and Damon,
we would be throwing jokes back and forth
and it was a blast.
And my character was so much fun
'cause he got to be a master of disguise.
And there's some, I hope they put it on the extras,
but I tried to do a French accent.
Do you wanna give us a sample of that?
Well, I mean, hu-hu-hu,
it wasn't that good.
(Drew laughing)
It wasn't good.
(audience clapping)
Only gonna be in the extras of the video.
I love it, I'm reading
what all like the critics are saying,
'cause I am like, "God, I found this movie
so intelligent, and riveting, and like a unique tone,"
and they're all saying the same thing.
So I'm like, "Oh, awesome."
So stupendous job and thank you
for all of us parents who are sitting on the, you know,
watching the kids.
You're welcome.
(upbeat music)